all right matthew hey mark how you doing
welcome back thank you so so your video
which i didn't expect any kind of
unusual response from
became like i think the most popular
video in the last probably 12 months or
almost
almost 12 months of my yeah my channel
which tells me a lot about
what some of my audience is into yeah
but uh tell me where you're at today so
last time you were
you're a functional heroin addict right
you had a job
which you know can be debated um by
people so
um and you know it's so it's functional
to an extent
like i mentioned last time the the money
issue is a big deal and you know when
the money runs out
it really sucks and i i guess i didn't
emphasize that enough
that i i was just i was in a really good
mood last time which you know i'm in a
good mood right now but
you know after watching the video and
reading comments and stuff
i realized that maybe i should have been
a little bit more
um explain a little bit more about the
downsides of it
because they're it's obviously not all
just happy-go-lucky you know
like everything's great all the time um
so you've been through some rough times
you and i have spoken off
yeah yeah it's just i mean i'm 35 years
old
i'm uh i mean i live in in a room i rent
a room with roommates i
have a few good friends and um some
close family but
besides that like i mean with the
addiction
sorry i kind of getting jumbled up here
um
i i get depressed i mean i'm i since i
was a teenager i mean i've had
depression issues but i've never
gone to a doctor got medication or
anything i've just
never been that kind of person i've
always tried to just
deal with things on my own and didn't
want to be ironically didn't want to be
on
prescribed drugs which you know i
eventually got into legal drugs which
you know but um yeah there's been times
recently where i've been
depressed i mean when when the stuff
runs out and you start to
uh experience withdrawals i mean it
generally takes about
12 hours for it to set in so from the
last hit i take when the stuff's gone
about 12 hours later i'll start yawning
i'll start getting sleepy
then i'll start getting maybe cold sweat
a little bit sweaty
and then it starts getting the stomach
sickness and that's when it's really bad
when my stomach's really in pain
and i have to be close to a bathroom
because that's just the way it goes with
withdrawals
and uh unfortunately it gets that way
sometimes because i haven't managed my
money properly i know in the video last
time i said
you know i've learned to space things
out and i mean that for the most part
does work
but i i have i have low self-control i
have self-control issues and so
i definitely will smoke the last of it
and then not know when i'm gonna get
more or you know well i know eventually
it'll happen but you know how many hours
or so
there's days where i'm just laying in
bed just
waiting to hear from the dealer and like
don't want to leave the bed i don't want
to watch
tv i don't even look at my phone i don't
want to text anybody i don't
want to deal with anything in fact just
looking at the phone
the other day while i was feeling that
way i was just like this is such a leash
to me like i have
all these notifications from all these
different things and it's also trivial
like
i would love to just throw it away and
just not have to deal with it like
i can just imagine like you know if i
lived 20 30 years ago
which you know people said it looked
like i was from the 60s or 70s
maybe it would have been better off
maybe i would have been better off then
i don't know
but you know here i am now but um
yes i i definitely get depressed i get
the
withdrawals usually i can get it taken
care of within a few hours
so i'm able to smoke some and then i
feel great again and i can go walk work
do whatever clean my room but if i'm
withdrawing i'm not leaving the bed
i i go in between like putting all the
covers on me because i'm cold and then
it's too hot and then i want them off
and
open the window close the window stuff
like that if you're working
if it's a work day do you make it to
work or do you blow it off i
i try my best not to let that happen i
try to um
to to get to work there's been a couple
times where i've had to call out sick
because it just
you know didn't work out with the time
but i try to avoid that
even if i have to just be late because
i'd rather be late than
not you know um i actually have two jobs
now
i got the job that i had mentioned in
the previous video that i was waiting
for i
waited three months for that video i
mean for that interview
uh good job for the job actually i did
three interviews uh
so i eventually got it i'm waiting for
the medical coverage to kick in
it takes about three months um you have
to hit a certain amount of hours
and i'm about a third of the way there
so in a couple months a lot of medical
coverage i'm
gonna go look and to you know see what
the best solution for me is to get off
this because
i don't have the luxury to just
disappear for from my life
and go somewhere i'd love to i'd love to
just say forget it
but it's like where does all my stuff go
who pays the rent
or what do i so i got to figure all that
out it would
ideal situation i mean seeing
amanda's video in that entire thing
sorry that i mean that was you know that
was really um
that impacted me a lot i think it
impacted a lot of people and
a lot of people really cared about her
and she was a really sweet person and
it was really sad you know what happened
to her but she was seemed like on such a
great path
and watching the videos that um lima had
posted of her in the rehab you know she
seemed so happy and
um like i was like god i'd love to you
know get away and do something like that
because
i mean what you've said and what lima
said is
the the rehab process of going somewhere
for 30 days which i also mentioned in
the last video that
oh if i could disappear for 30 days you
know that would help it's it's
like like people said it's not enough
you know
a year is obviously ideal but most
people don't have that luxury you know
of
of disappearing for a year but when
you're in dire circumstances like she
was
you know then um there's really no other
solution
um i mean i've been this is eight years
now that i've been addicted to opiates
um
it's only been two or three with heroin
but um the the withdrawal symptoms
have changed or evolved over time i
don't know if it's
the drug i don't know if it's my body
getting used to it or
the quality or yes the quality or if
it's
how much fentanyl is in it nowadays you
know because last time i went to
methadone clinic and they tested me for
drugs they showed me this and this is in
your system
at the very bottom they said fentanyl
and so i'm not
seeking out fentanyl so it's in the
heroin
um but yes i i would i i'd like to
to get away and start over fresh and be
removed from
society where i have i mean my mind
i just it races sometimes and i'm just
like i i probably have add or adhd or
whatever because i just
can't i'm not content with just sitting
down and watching tv
and watching a movie that's why i love
watching movies at home because i could
pause it
i can do whatever the hell i want when
i'm in a theater like
i went and saw a movie a couple weeks
ago i had to go the bathroom a few times
and i'm like rushing to take a few hits
and get back some missed part of the
movie you know and that's that's no way
to live
you know i remember when i used to go to
movies and you know just enjoy myself
with a friend and
i don't even i don't even want to hang
out with people a lot of the time i just
want to be alone in my room and uh
it sucks just like isolating and
so yeah it's not all it's not all happy
you know everything's great
and fun and everything over time it
it's i used to get high and go walk
around
berkeley or san francisco and go eat and
drink and
go shop and stuff or call friends or
go to a comedy show or a concert and
i mean also with covet in the past year
that's kind of
affected things as well so i feel like
the combination of kovid
and me kind of just getting
a little bit deeper into addiction i
feel like it's just
i don't i don't do anything really i i
work
and i and i sit at home and sometimes
i'll go out to eat with a friend or
family member but
it's pretty rare so i don't mean for
this to be some sob story or anything
i'm just trying to be
honest you know not that i wasn't honest
last time i just
i feel like i sh it seemed like i sugar
coated it although i wasn't
um intentionally uh consciously doing it
it's just i was in a good mood
and it was the first interview and i was
yeah
that just happened but since that first
interview you and i have spoken on the
phone a couple times yeah and you were
i think you know you had thoughts of
suicide yeah no i've
the depression gets pretty heavy since i
was a teenager i've had thoughts of that
and uh i mean
god when i was 14 years old i mean i was
like sitting there in the classroom like
blasting slipknot in my headphones and
like marilyn manson and [ __ ] like
being depressed but that you know
looking back that was so trivial as a 14
year old to feel that way and not
be enjoying life but you can't you don't
know that at that time you know you
learn later
um and so throughout time yes i've had
depression issues and thoughts of
suicide i've never
acted anything out the you know closest
to anything was the
time i overdosed on fentanyl which is
when i said i don't care and i was
drinking
which it wasn't like hey i want to die
it was just
being careless and stupid um so yeah
since then
it's it's never to the point where i'm
like going and buying a gun or like
cutting myself or taking a bunch of
pills it's just
thinking god if i just died like
i mean obviously i wouldn't have to
think about anything anymore but
like sometimes i feel like my family or
my friends like
like i feel like they i just feel like
such a shitty friend or family member
like
i just wish i could be a better friend
or
a family member to them and and i feel
bad because i know they care about me
and they're
worried you know um i mean there was
a couple months ago i had a moving sale
i was moving places
and my mom came over to help me and
at one point throughout the day i knew
my dealer was gonna come by
and my mom i didn't know she wasn't stay
there the whole day so i'm sitting there
i'm thinking
well great how is this going to work out
because she's not stupid and i'm not
going to lie to her because i just
don't want to be that kind of person and
so
i told her i said you know this is
what's happening and she said you know i
know
that's what you do so whatever just go
ahead and do it and
she just went over to the car while he
came and he's like i feel bad doing this
in front of your mom and i'm like
this is such a [ __ ] weird situation
you know like
like i mean because people's idea of you
know heroin
addiction stuff that people are out on
the streets and you know nodding off
and you know but here i am at a moving
sale
my mom's helping me and i'm like doing
this transaction like
civilly and going you know hiding in the
bathroom and
i don't know it's a weird life to live
and i don't want to live it anymore i
want to get help
i just have to wait for the medical
coverage we do have an employee
assistance program at my job
that has like free counseling and i just
got that number the other day so i was
going gonna call it just to see
if they can do anything you know before
i have medical
coverage but um i don't know for now i'm
just
in limbo and i still have a roof over my
head you know i'm still alive i'm
i have two jobs like i said um
ironically enough i'm a lifeguard
um so yeah i uh
i watch i watch over a pool at a very
high class community
upscale community you don't look like an
addict at all i know yeah
and so no there's nobody you know
there was one time a couple years ago
that the dealer came up there and that
[ __ ] was nodding off in the hot tub and
some guy was like
what's up with that guy and i was like
oh i don't know i think he's on some
medication or something you know
but um uh yeah i'm
i'm still functioning
was another thing you know that it's a
debate of how functional somebody is if
they're functional or if that's even the
right term to use
i don't know i don't care all i know is
that i'm doing my best
and i'm staying true to myself the best
i can
i don't i try not to lie to people even
when it comes to like i said my mom like
i was just
i'm gonna be honest with her i don't
steal i know
uh somebody said on the comments
somebody better notify
find out where he works notify his job
because he's probably stealing to fund
his habit
no that's not the case you didn't lose
your job from the video no
ah no but i actually showed some people
at the job and they were
their minds were blown it's interesting
to me how like if i do
a stripper interview or three as i did
recently from my trip to tampa
now i got dozens and dozens of strippers
around the country that want me
to come and do interviews with them and
that that happens with
with swingers or nudists or appellations
or whatever i am
doing but with your video which you know
certainly was very popular
2.6 million views right a year which is
a lot yeah
i've got very few people that want to
come out and talk about right
certainly there's a lot of people that
are using these kind of these harder
drugs
and and being functional yeah but just
don't have the courage to come out and
talk about it yeah and i've had some you
had no negative repercussions from it
i'm not saying everyone should do it but
right although the new job i have
ever since i started there it seems like
the younger people there's something i
feel like
i i've told my also another thing i said
in the last video was girlfriend
girlfriend girlfriend she's not my
girlfriend i just said it because it's
easier than explaining the whole thing
we she broke up with me in september we
still talk every day we're
you know we have every intention of
being together eventually i just have to
get clean and i'm not gonna do that to
her to make her
deal with that you know in a
relationship so
um hold on a second um so yeah i just
don't
want to um be unfair to her so i did
have
multiple people reach out to me and say
that they were dealing with similar
things and you know or they felt the
same exact way
and i think it's very common yeah
yeah and they were like i'm too afraid
to say anything like a lot of people are
afraid that they're going to be
found out by their job um which i don't
even know how legal that would be to
fire somebody
over i mean maybe they'd have to find
some other way around it to act like
they were firing them for something else
but i don't think
i don't know if legally you could go up
somebody say hey i saw your interview
especially when it's a circumstance like
this where i'm like
hey i want to get help and i know it's
wrong and like i'm doing everything i
can and i'm trying to
you know still be a good person
everything it's not like i was just like
yeah [ __ ] it dude i'm partying you know
like
it's not like that no but it's not it's
not it's not a good thing to
have the world know that you are right
right yes and
you know there's times where at jobs
i'll have to
sneak off to the bathroom and do it you
know i try to keep that to a minimum
because i don't want
that to you know turn into a thing you
know um
but i think your your ability to be
honest about your
life yeah and behavior i think is
probably
helping you no yeah no it's it's
it's nice and then uh helps others yeah
there was one guy that said that um
man i mean i i don't know how much
of the story he gave me or whatever but
i guess you him and his wife were having
some problems and he had two young
daughters and he was going to hang
himself
and then he saw the video and i i don't
know what
about me or the video made him feel
they didn't want to do that but that's
what happened and so that's what he said
and he messaged me on instagram and
thanked me and
you know tells me about his life here
and there and i just feel bad because i
just feel like
i don't know um like
the right things to say or like if i
could help him more or
you know so i think just sharing your
story that's
doing your part yeah yeah then i got
you know the um random
girls that want to mess with me and mess
with my head and you and patrick and
eric and lois and everybody yeah
like i'm i'm 35 years old dude i'm over
it like i've
i've heard it all like sorry i don't
mean to sound like you know
mr player like cool guy or whatever but
um
it was just it's like there was one girl
it's like i'm gonna i'm gonna move from
seattle california i'm gonna come
live with you and see and like all this
stuff and i did get wrapped up in it
and like then i realized it was just it
was
nonsense and that she was nuts and so i
was like no forget it and then i went to
my ex-girlfriend freaking cried my eyes
out it was like i'm so sorry like i
almost
you know fell for this you know and
that was an eye-opener like okay i've
already
moved across country for two girls off
the internet in my life so
i don't need to be dealing with that
crap anymore if they're not
near me then it's not worth coming on
this
on my youtube channel and shared your
story sharing your story
um have you learned anything from doing
this um
that you're i guess i mean you were very
open and honest about something that
most people would keep them
keep hidden yeah i mean
it i don't know if it was because i get
i guess just
over all the video and then everything
else in my life and just
you know people saying like oh if his
job finds out or like
this or that about his life it made me
just think about everything as a whole
and just remember that i need to be
careful
um with with how i act what i do
like going to the bathroom or being late
or just
i need to be i can't get you can never
get um too
comfortable with it being an addict you
always have to be on your toes and
remember that it's not socially
acceptable people aren't going to get it
they're not going to
want to get it and you can talk to your
blue in the face to some people and
they're
not going to care so uh it's just
uh i just got to keep it under wraps the
best i can
as i'm doing another video but
i feel like uh this it doesn't
if it has gotten to the people that it
would bother they
haven't reacted or treated me any
differently which i'm very
grateful for um are you doing a good job
at work and you're
yeah no i i i the only thing is
and it's totally trivial is having the
two jobs
the schedule started to conflict and so
i was trying to like
leave one early one day and then be late
to one the next day or vice versa kind
of split it up
and neither would work with me and so
it's like i'm trying not to
have anybody know i'm a heroin addict
but at the same time i'm trying to just
have a normal schedule as a human
without the drug thing
and that was so i was like okay i had to
change my schedule and it's more of a
problem
yeah i just don't want to have any
issues that could cause any
for somebody to say hey we know what's
going on with you and that's probably
why you're late
or you know and then you know
i don't want to deal with that so so
from here you're you're hoping that
maybe
you'll find a way to get clean yeah
definitely 100
um i just think i would you recommend
this lifestyle for anyone
no no i wouldn't because like i said the
withdrawals are terrible and
it's just that it's like your body is a
ticking time bomb
you're just it's inevitable there's not
going to be a way that one day you're
going to wake up and escape it
or find some way to easily wean off of
it
because there's been times where even i
have done that i've gradually
lowered my usage and then like once the
withdrawals hit just take the tiniest
hit
and then ease into it a little bit
better but then once you get past it and
this stuff's gone your body it's in your
mind it's instantly
oh god that would just be sound so great
and i'd feel so much better
like yeah even i got over the shitty
part of the withdrawals
but i still could feel good again you
know better so
i don't know if it's going to take
medication or just some long
program i just don't want to do
methadone again i did that before and
based on stuff other people have said um
they said it's changed people for the
worse it's changed other people for the
better
it seems like it's really hit or miss
but the couple months i was on it
i wasn't feeling great it didn't seem
like a solution to me
um so maybe suboxone um
i don't know i gotta figure it out once
the medical kicks in
and like i said i have the other
employee assistance program to call
and see if they can help but um for now
i'm just
trying to get by and make sure to pay
rent and pay bills and
eat um which that's their thing and
sometimes like
the other day i didn't eat until like 5
p.m
because i was withdrawing and i didn't
want to get out of bed and
my stomach hurt and so it's just all
around unhealthy so i wouldn't recommend
it
and i'm not promoting it all right
matthew well thank you so much for
coming in and sharing your story and uh
i hope help you
figure out a way out and oh and then one
more thing i wanted to say
hi world hi youtube like amanda used to
say because that was really cute
thank you